let
kylie jenner freaking live thank you in
a sneak peek at the upcoming season of
keeping up with the kardashians
the famous fam gets together for a night
out in palm springs
but before they hit the town the 23 year
old beauty mogul decides she wants to
take a few shots
and her mama kris jenner isn't feeling
it
should we take a shot i'm not gonna be a
shot girl tonight's a different kind of
night
my question is once i start drinking
tequila
to static tequila drinking 101
don't mix alcohol exactly okay so coco
backed out of that pre-dinner shot
but chris's longtime boyfriend corey
gamble was
super down just take the shot with me i
would do whatever we do this is how we
live
here's a fun game take a shot every time
kris jenner looks peeved
anybody
[Music]
kylie and corey let's go
it's supposed to be a fun sister night
patience and no stretch to patience
seriously just bring me the whole bottle
they have a bar
at the restaurant i don't care
go boy anyway the famous momager might
have been ready to go
af but kylie and corey were taking their
sweet time
we don't rush we just we just we float
through life like unicorns you feel me
um do unicorns float to chris
to chris patience and no stretch to
patience and no stress
[Applause]
let's go scott
whoa i think you should paste it the
first shot is always the hardest
car yeah kylie is liv
ing living and on monday the reality
star turned
23 jetting off with her nearest and
dearest for a tropical vacay celebration
i'm excited about it the b-day girl
shared this shot on instagram
that's kylie with her daughter stormy
looking out at the sunset
and in another post she thanked olivier
rousting for making her one
seriously fire birthday dress i'm having
so much fun
kylie sis kendall jenner shared a few
beat shots on her insta story
and chloe posted this video of some
festive fireworks
rob kardashian was also in attendance
and shared a bunch of pics from the
getaway
including one with chloe's ex tristan
thompson
rob's doing great he really is he
captioned the pics quote
most beautiful trip of my life with the
fam
happy birthday kylie jenner love you